Laura's with us in Nashville to start
off this hour hey Laura how are you are
you better than I deserve what's up in
your world okay I just had a question
I've recently purchased your total
makeover and but I'm having some issues
with being overdrawn
in my bank and checks returned over the
last week and a half or so and my
question is basically what's the best
way to get out of this situation so that
I can start working on my Total Money
Makeover okay do you know how to
reconcile your checkbook are your
checking account using your bank's
website okay it's called balancing your
checkbook is the thing and what you're
doing is you're not just checking your
balance every day you actually know that
I've written or I have used the debit
card or whatever these these many
charges that have not yet hit the bank
and if they were to hit the bank today I
would be an overdraft and that keeps you
from being in overdraft and basically we
don't obviously you don't want to commit
to more money than is in the account and
you've got to get the accounting part of
that working so what I do is contact
your bank do they do you have online
banking with them okay contact them and
they'll walk you through how to do that
because you watch what you're doing is
you're writing obviously writing checks
or you know your debit card or whatever
authorizing some kind of withdrawal
beyond what your balance is right you
know that and it's very very expensive
yes
one of the charging you per hit Wow
yeah that'll add up fast I mean ten of
those is like some money right how many
how many hits have you had over the last
week six or seven I was expecting which
that's my fault
is expecting some money through my job
that didn't come through no you wrote
money euro checks on money than what in
the account to pay some bills and it
ended up not going through because of a
system change so no it is it is and the
thing is you've just got to never do
that again the rest of your life it's
just too expensive and too embarrassing
and everything else
and so it just creates too big a mess
and so you've got to just know what your
balance is without having to check it
every single day and you should be able
to run that you know with your standard
bank software most of them have it and
once you know what it is then the trick
of course is don't ride against
something you think is coming ever again
it's got to be in there before you ride
against it does that make sense okay now
how do we get out of this mess we get
others mess by prioritizing the money
that you do have did the system change
did you get end up getting the money out
of it now they're switching payroll yeah
and so they still haven't gotten you the
money right and it was they're switching
paychecks they're going through a
totally different system so it may be
July before that's even available Wow
what about the rest year pay well the
rest of my pay is family and I bring
home about between 1250 and 1300 and
it's coming through normal okay okay so
we're going to use that and then when
the rest of that that other thing comes
in maybe in July in a couple of weeks
hopefully you'll be use that to get
completely squared around so here's what
we do we prioritize from most important
to least important thing in your whole
world and so here they'll help you that
the first thing you buy with the money
you have is food they're not not eating
out just poop you feed your kids you
feed yourself right whatever then the
second thing you buys lights and water
was any of those two things what bounced
okay good so lights and water and food
now we live to fight another day right
how about your rent or your mortgage
payment actually right now I'm living
with my parents so I don't have oh
that's wonderful
okay that's wonderful that's helpful
okay so basic necessities
survival or what we do first it's food
shelter clothing transportation and
utilities okay so you have a car payment
yes is it current yes sir good okay
so what type of stuff bounced actually
trying to start getting paid off also
like that finance one okay I like things
like that so this is more than anything
this is embarrassing and stressful but
it doesn't really affect your life today
so what you do just make a list of those
things I probably would say whatever the
smallest one is I just go ahead and get
it cleaned up the payment amount not the
balance okay so list out these checks
these bounced items how many did you say
if there were again okay just list them
out from smallest to largest item size
and then let's just work get it get the
little one knocked off to the next level
and so every time we do that what are
they total up to without the charges
they equal about I would say $800 okay
all right so gonna take a little while
to get through them with your pay scale
all right good so you just list them out
smallest to largest like that and then
the bank charges themselves you're
probably not going to get out of but you
can go in and sit down talk to your
branch manager and try to talk them into
waiving them because unless you've been
a serial overdraft if your serial
overdraft they just they just love you
because you they stay open on you then
okay but if it's a one time thing and
they like okay they might cut you some
slack and refund the actual companies
that are trying to charge you overdraft
charges to for bounced checks some of
them will waive them if you just call
and cry you know calling cry river and
and I'd try that because that's going to
help you get through these that much
faster and get them squared around and
just try to talk them out of it in other
words as much as you can but but just
push through and list them smallest to
largest or if one of them is really
really super important it's not one of
the items we touched on but it's a big
big deal of some kind then go ahead and
move it and make it first I don't care
but the good news is by the middle to
the end of July you'll be current again
that's what you know August 1 Laura
in a different world is that right
correct okay and never again and then
jump on every dollar calm and download
the budget and get yourself on a budget
so you know where all this money's
coming from and where it's all going to
and every dollar that comes our
budgeting software that's free to use
it's a free app for your phone your
iPhone their your girl Android or
whatever and you're completely taking
care of their jump on there and start
building out your budget and then let's
begin to work those baby steps once
you're current and what you're out of
overdraft then you begin to work your
baby steps and you lay out a game plan
to work your way all the way through and
you know get yourself up into some
emergency fund you're debt-free you
start building some wealth you move out
on your own all those kinds of things
and that's where you're headed towards
and you'll be there shortly if you just
be very very intentional the bad news is
you're learning the expensive lesson the
good news is if you learned it you'll
never have to learn it again
i'ma bounced to check in 40 years but I
had to learn that I just don't write
checks if there's no money